Today, we're taking a look at
the difference between helium,
regular air, and sulfur
hexafluoride in balloons.
[Music]
On Twitter, user
Monkey Humor said,
"Hey @theKingofRandom,
can you inhale helium
then blow up a balloon?"
As I interpret that question,
the goal is to see
if we can inhale helium,
sort of straight from the tank,
then blow it into a balloon,
and still get
a balloon that floats,
and I'm particularly
intrigued by this
because I think I've seen this
in cartoons growing
up all the time.
People would just
blow up a balloon,
and then it would float away,
and once I understood
anything about science
and buoyancy, I thought,
"Hey, why is that happening?"
"What is in their lungs
that they can blow up a balloon
that floats away?"
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to try
breathing in helium,
then breathing it
into a balloon to see
if we can blow up a balloon
with our breathe
that will float.
Not only are we going
to try this with helium,
but we're actually going to try
sort of the opposite as well.
We're going to take
some sulfur hexafluoride,
which you might remember
is the deep voice gas,
and breathe it in,
and our voice comes
out sounding like this.
So we want to try
the same idea with that,
breathe sulfur hexafluoride in,
breathe that out
into a balloon.
See what happens.
We also might see what happens
if we mix the two.
I feel like this is a race.
So you're saying we
each take a tank.
We each take a balloon.
Yes.
And we see who can breathe
into a balloon,
>> and get it to float fastest.
>> Fastest.
It's not incredibly safe
to breathe directly
from the tank into your lungs
and into a balloon.
So I think that we need
to fill up a balloon,
breathe from that balloon,
and then into
a second balloon.
If we start
to feel light-headed,
we have to tap out.
No passing out in this contest.
Guys, helium displaces
the air in your lungs.
If you breathe
in too much of it,
you will get lightheaded
because you are
technically asphyxiating.
You do want to stop
if you get lightheaded.
That's not good.
Fortunately, helium does rise,
and so it does kind of try
and escape your lungs,
and regular air tries
to fill it back in.
But if you're just breathing
helium in over and over,
there's a good chance
that the regular air won't have
enough time to get in there.
So we'll definitely want
to take some breaths
in between moving
from one balloon to the other.
Go.
[Music]
Oh, there's light headedness.
I feel it.
>> Ha ha.
>> No!
It's floating.
Oh boy.
I'm not floating.
Going down.
See how I stopped
and took a breath.
I'm fine.
We breathe a balloon
that floats into the air,
like something straight
out of a cartoon.
So this is not 100% helium
that we've got in these,
because our tanks
don't have 100% helium.
These are 80%,
plus the fact that we
still had some oxygen,
carbon dioxide in our lungs.
And nitrogen.
The tanks and our lungs
also had nitrogen.
So helium, nitrogen,
oxygen, carbon, dioxide
and trace other elements.
I'm going to blow up
another balloon with helium,
and I'm going to try and match
it to the size of this one.
3, 2, 1.
Okay.
Smoked it.
There's our difference
right there.
So we've definitely got
more helium in this one.
This is less dense,
and you can definitely see
that they do not take off
of the same speed as a result.
All right.
I also want to test like
the lifting capacity of these.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to tie strings
onto the bottom of them,
and then slowly add weights,
and see how much weight
each one can take.
Mine is already
slowed down with 3.
Just a little.
All right.
Wait, what's yours at?
Mine is currently
at 11 paper clips,
and it's just-- Look at this.
It's like almost perfectly even.
It's barely going down.
That's awesome.
And I took one off of mine,
so now, I'm at 10,
and mine's going up.
So for me, 10 is the most,
and for you,
4 is the most.
It is,
but mine is also being held up
by static electricity right now.
We are able to blow up
a balloon with our breath
that then floats.
It doesn't float
in the air as much.
We have about half
as much weight on it,
and that's just pulling down.
So yes, it does work.
No, it does not work is filling
it directly from the tank.
Now, we want to try sort
of the opposite direction.
We want to see
if we can make heavier
than air balloons
even more than normal.
This balloon is now full
of sulfur hexafluoride.
If you haven't seen as using
sulfur hexafluoride before,
there's a couple
of neat things about it.
The first is
that it's about 6
times more dense than air,
which means that it's
heavy for a balloon.
The other thing that it's known
for is having an opposite effect
on your voice as helium.
Instead of making
your voice high,
it makes your voice low.
Pretty cool.
We're gonna make a helium-sulfur
hexafluoride cocktail.
[Music]
[inaudible.]
Okay, is it--
Oh, okay.
Sulfut hexafloride's
definitely winning here.
This one is sulfur hexafluoride.
This one has just normal breath.
[Music]
It's pulling down pretty hard.
Helium is lighter than air,
but not nearly as
much lighter as
sulfur hexafluoride is heavier.
So it overcomes
it pretty easily.
I think we need to move on
to our next experiment.
To start this experiment off,
we've got a balloon
filled with breath
in a container full of just air.
So this is a little bit heavier
than the air around it,
just because it has a little bit
higher concentration
of carbon dioxide,
and because it has
a balloon around it.
The balloon in
itself adds weight.
But now, what we're going to do
is introduce a gas into the box
that's way heavier than the air,
and even the carbon dioxide
in that balloon.
Look at that.
So that is a balloon
that was sinking in regular air.
From the box was full of just
the normal air around us,
it's going straight
to the bottom.
Now, it's floating.
Helium balloon into
sulfur hexafluoride.
That's going well.
Wow, that has a lot
of resistance on it.
Does it?
Yeah, it's kind of like trying
to push a ball down into water.
This is the one
that had sulfur hexafluoride
and some helium in it.
Right to the bottom.
Makes sense.
Sinks right through.
Well, this one
is still floating.
Can we fill a balloon
with our breath that will sink
into the sulfur hexafluoride?
How do you gonna do that?
Same way, fill a balloon
with sulfur hexafluoride,
breathe out of that balloon,
breathe in to the other balloon.
Maybe take a couple gap breaths
to keep from passing out,
and just do the same thing,
blowing up a balloon,
see if we can get it to sink.
I'm going to stand behind him
in case he blacks out.
Thank you.
[Music]
You're good.
Taking a breather here.
[Music]
Mostly better.
Still in there.
>> Yeah.
>> Hang on.
>> You survived.
>> Still a little bit lightheaded.
Let me just fill the rest.
All right.
Let's see these two.
This one, I'm gonna label as
sulfur hexafluoride breath.
This one is oxygen,
but if anyone was ever wondering
how bad my handwriting is.
All right, hang on.
I do want to refill this box.
Toss that in,
see how it's doing.
Lovely.
Yes, perfect.
Here is your breath balloon.
Sulfur hexafluoride breath.
Did it work?
It worked.
Sinks right down through.
Sulfur hexafluoride,
much heavier than air,
but it's not the only gas
that's heavier than air.
Carbon Dioxide is
also heavier than air,
and while we breathe
out some of it,
still what we breathe
out is mostly nitrogen
with a fair amount
of oxygen still mixed in there.
But we do have
a good way of getting
a concentrated carbon dioxide.
We want to get this carbon
dioxide out of the dry ice,
and into this balloon.
So we're going to use a little
bit of hot water to do so.
[Music]
That looks pretty good.
Compare it with the SF6, is it--
Which is--
The sulfur hexafluoride is still
much heavier than
the carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide
versus just breath.
I would say the carbon dioxide
feels a little bit heavier.
There you go.
That's a good
demonstration right there.
Definitely heavier.
Let's see how it does
in our sulfur hexafluoride box.
Yep, floats nicely.
Carbon dioxide balloon.
That's sinks right
down through it.
Cool.
Very clear demonstration
that the carbon
dioxide is heavier.
You know what else
we could do though.
We might be able
to actually weigh these.
To start out though,
we're just going to take
an uninflated balloon,
and we're going to set
that right on the scale.
That is showing up as 3.2 grams.
2.85 for this one.
2.9 for that one.
I'm going back
to this yellow one.
Was that really
that much heavier?
3.2.
That's a heavier balloon.
I'm going to take this,
and I'm going to press tear.
That's going to level it out.
That means that
with a balloon on it,
that's what it's going
to register as 0.
Now, if I take a balloon off,
that should go down
to negative that much.
Now, here we have a balloon
that is full of breath.
Now, we were getting a result
of about 3.5 grams.
This is a very sensitive scale.
However, if I just push
my hand down above this,
it easily registers
on the scale, just the air
pushing down on the balloon.
So about 3.5 grams.
It was resting up
against the back of this.
But let's try the CO2.
I think that's going to be
the next closest result.
That is showing up as
about 8.5 grams so...
Holy cow!
3.5 grams for just
breath up to...
Well, maybe even 9.5.
That's kind of
where it's registering now.
Sulfur hexafluoride.
What is it?
Well, if I can get
it to stay on there,
it's up about 30 grams.
Oh my gosh.
Bounce.
Come on balloon.
Almost ten times as
heavy as breath.
Yeah.
Really significant difference
between the sulfur hexafluoride
and the breath balloon.
[Music]
Apparently, there's something
very scratchy inside our box.
3 balloons just
spontaneously exploded,
all in a row,
and we don't know
what caused it.
There is another thing
I do want to test,
because I suspect a lot
of you will want to see it
and that is breathing
in sulfur hexafluoride,
and then breathing in helium,
and seeing what
the result is.
Not mixing them.
I suspect it's going to be
like your balloon.
Now, lungs are actually
not like balloons.
They're often depicted that way.
They're really more
like a sponge material
on the inside.
So it's not just
a bag full of air.
I'm just going to try and like
hold my breath for a second,
and then I'm going to breathe
helium on top of that,
and I'm going to see
if it's possible to get
like a layered voice effect,
where I have like
helium up first,
and then the voice
goes down to here.
[Music]
Where's your voice at?
Right here.
Wow.
[Music]
Okay, what result am I getting?
That's actually kind of strange.
I am getting almost a mix.
Now, it's just
sulfur hexafluoride.
And now, I need to breathe.
But it worked for half a second.
That was cool.
This time, I'm going
to try it again,
and have just a little bit
of sulfur hexafluoride, and then
like the rest of this helium.
Take some deep breaths
for a second.
Your lips have gone glue again.
[Music]
Is it--
Okay.
[Music]
Now, starting out,
it's actually fairly normal.
I heard a tiny bit
of squeak for a second.
I'm just going to keep talking,
and I don't know
what's going to happen,
or if there was
enough sulfur hexafluoride
to make any difference at all.
I am kind of running
out of breath though.
So if there is
any sulfur hexafluoride,
I'm going to hit it soon.
I don't think it's gonna happen.
There wasn't enough in there.
The helium went out.
So you can overpower
it with helium,
but mostly it just
made my voice normal.
Like to me,
it didn't sound that weird.
It didn't change that much.
So I think they did mix,
but they mixed
in just the right ratio
that they're just like,
eh, call it a wash.
Monkey Humor, thank you
for your suggestion.
Editors, if we can find
a picture of Dr. Doofenshmirtz
with Mr. Balloony,
just flash that image up
on the screen at some point.
Guys, that's not all.
You know, we've always got more
for you to see.
That box at the top is going
to take you to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube think you
should be watching next,
and if you hit
this bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel,
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.